I think it's safe to say that Valerie is
having a bit of a coming-out party right
now I mean new agent new game new map
and its first big tournament won by the
likes of skadoodle and Brax but this is
far from a perfect game and this past
Wednesday on Twitch over at twitch.tv
slash to score eSports on our weekly
show clouded calling Dan Devon and I got
together to talk about everything we
think is holding the game back from how
broken the OP is to just how uncreate of
brimstone can sometimes feel so Ken this
can actually compete with csgo you guys
might know what Colin thinks but stay
tuned and find out
[Music]
enemy remaining look it's cool I mean
aside from a few of those they they kind
of gave him the 1b ones that's true to
be honest with you like the two guys
heaven is that what that's called on a
scent heaven yeah
the two guys heaven I mean they made a
good play with the flash and the one guy
peeked I wish the guy on the other side
of peaked as well so I would have been
dead but I mean yeah it's awesome it's
just uh yeah there's only one guy left
come on guys don't get ya brag
it's why sure this guy's just gonna kill
you it's also like that really did
resemble so much here like cs1 p5
basically like not not necessarily and
that like you know they were lining up
for one do one's run over but in terms
of like there's not really much ability
usage in like an interesting way and
that way five they're like there's a
flash and that's about it
you know like everything else is just
like straight gunplay from from all
sides so it's just like that was like
fine but it doesn't feel like wow this
is the kind of thing I can only see the
bow I don't want it like well I gotta go
up like Baumer right now that's the part
of the purpose of like we're not looks
like no there's not a strip like part of
the purpose of these eSports events
stuff like that is to drum up interest
in people playing the game and I
definitely don't watch that and be like
wow that's battering I gotta get into
Valerie and I do like the game and I do
like playing it a lot but like that was
not a moment that like screams like yes
Valerie it's like oh this is just like
doesn't see us go this is what 60s go
this is actually an insane segue into
what I want to talk about it's a little
clip from shroud where he talks about
the utility in ballard and the kind of
skill cap on the game the thing is this
game is this the skill the skill ceiling
and the potential is a lot lower than a
game like counter-strike right so a Z K
Brax doodle
right legends insane
but they're capped they're capped right
so everybody else is gonna be on their
level and they're gonna have to use
their brain to figure out how to beat
them in counter-strike it's not so much
like that the cap there's a cap of
course but the cap is so high up there
that sometimes you don't even need a
brain you could just be [__] insane
doesn't work like that in this game why
do you think the capsular on this game
this game is trying to reach people that
don't play FPS a lot of people that have
been playing valor n't never touched a
first-person shooter in their lives but
valor n't allows them to so it's not as
punishing right it's it's obvious enough
when you see when you play brimstone or
you play helmet and you push one button
and you get this old view I want to
smoke here I want to smoke here that
right there can show you how the game is
kind of dumbed down to make those lesser
players be at the top faster that's kind
of the goal with this the game the goal
with this game is to have a much easier
first-person shooter experience when I
first played Balor it like in the beta I
pick brimstone first because he has like
this he come he has three smokes which
by the way by itself is insane and he
and you don't need to you don't need to
learn anything you don't need to learn
one thing no lineup no timing nothing
you just look at a map and you're like
here here here it's so crazy to me it
feels dishonest you know if I think you
I can use that word when they started
showing off the agents and stuff in the
office and we were like wow so many of
these abilities are you know so csgo
shortcut right oh can boost yourself Oh
he just Auto puts a you know brimstone
automatically puts a smoke where you
want it to be right like so many
disabilities are just like here is the
quote unquote like macro shortcut to do
a billion CS by yourself without too
much effort again I definitely agree
with Shroud that that's on purpose by a
hundred percent agree that riot did this
oh sure to LIKE attract newcomers to the
game and I also agree that it probably
does limit the skill cap but it means
that either riot has to come up with new
characters whose abilities offer more
open-ended creativity because like let's
be real here brimstone putting three
smokes anywhere I'm up for it
no creativity more and you will find the
best possible smokes you're only gonna
put them there right talk about the clip
ability of an eSport the highlight
capacity the capacity to generate
highlights that's like what you were
saying I think we both felt the same way
when we watched the swag ace like we
were like a little underwhelmed like
which is crazy thing to say now part of
that is because of how the other team
played but like it goes to this point
right of like okay I'm not I'm not
saying that what riot has done here is a
bad thing you know when I say dishonest
it's like it's a little tongue-in-cheek
it's from the perspective yes go I do
think that what they're doing is
targeted towards a specific audience a
shroud set and that's it that's a good
thing but like we wanna be able to have
iconic moments in this eSport when it
gets going we you want the score you
sports to be making videos about your
versions of the earning defuse the Olaf
boost that you're bringing up in human
reactions and if we keep pumping out
characters who put three smokes down at
the click of a button you you are taking
away some of the tools for for the
greatest players in the world to create
those moments there are still the
characters out of creative abilities oh
man I think is like a really creative
interesting character to allows you to
do cool things that aren't just like
shortcuts basically yeah like I think
that's more interesting I think that
sova at least offer something that isn't
in csgo and does require Mike lineups
like I only play soba because I learned
my arrow line
and I will do those things and it's like
there is a look like element of like
okay I have learned the skill I am
executing on that skill I'm helping my
team with that like those kinds of
things are more interesting and offer
more creativity and and I think it's
either you make more characters that
allow that or you you know you kind of
tone down the effectiveness of those
ones that just sort of shortcut I don't
know right clearly right is doing this
on purpose and I think it's working at
somebody me personally I'm not you know
I don't play a lot of csgo I'm not good
at csgo um I feel much I don't think I'm
good at valor in either but I feel
better playing Bower if that makes any
sense right and I do think working the
reason I bring this up and the reason I
wanted to show the shroud clip is there
was something that went on on the
weekend that actually you know as a big
fan of the game made me kind of hold my
breath a little bit the first is that at
the highest level this game became like
an OP fest like you saw you saw teams
buying buying triple op and this is not
the mobile off like in csgo where you
watch people you know do do creative
things crazy [__] and they're able to
use the utility in creative ways use the
fact that the office mobile in creative
ways and that's where you get those
insane highlights but in in valiant the
OP is not mobile the utility is like
you're saying a much more
straightforward lacks a little bit of
creativity so at the highest level we
watched some of the best players so far
in the game more or less hold angles
with ops like just just straight-up hold
angles and make it very difficult to
walk into a site without getting off
yeah and there wasn't that there wasn't
the same punish there wasn't the same
like I don't care I can just I'm better
than you I'll beat you like once there
that teams were able to get their
economy into a place where they can they
can have multiple obscene was it very
difficult to come back even even though
there's obviously a risk associated with
buying a a 4500 credit gun but like I'm
saying it I I don't think the problem is
the off itself I think it's the lack of
utility and lack of lack of answers to
an OP holding an angle do they just like
I said I just think it's a problem with
there's not enough utility it needs to
be more utility in the game to be able
to take more map control aggressively on
attack
because I'm telling you right now at the
highest level of the majority of the
maps feel the majority of the maps feel
defense sided because the second team
start sopping it's super hard to play
around if you think about in
counter-strike people have people have a
team of encounter shake has ten flashes
five smokes so in this game you have two
maybe three maybe four flashes and you
have three maybe four maybe five smokes
for the entire round so the problem is
there's not enough utility right now
that counteroffers like the utility is a
great example because there just has to
be an element of sandbox to it there has
to be it can't be so linear right so
like in csgo it's just the the
incredible utility use comes with the
freedom right so let's say you get rid
of certain sky boxes or whatever and
it's just like okay you start in this
bond you have access to smokes what what
can you do
okay can you come up with a line up that
that smokes window from spawn or Xbox
from spawn or can you come up with a
perfect three smoke wall line up to lock
out a site on Mirage like yeah you can
figure it out it's not at the principle
button it's like figure it out and then
when somebody figures something out and
they do it you're like oh somebody in
the chat was like when I when I brought
this over example like oh well once you
learn so they lineups they're exactly
the same as like well well they're not
necessarily because you're not going to
be doing the same ones every time and
sometimes on the fly you need to figure
out where to put that in a way that's
creative right it's one of the few
examples in this game that I do feel
like strongly and I think one of the
reasons so many teams were for running
it this weekend is that like vision is
powerful but also vision where you want
it when you want it that requires skill
to get it there is is really powerful
and that character would not be very
interesting if it was just brimstone Sal
smokes and it's one of those thing from
so Sal's most art very interesting
because it takes away they're like how
do I figure this out and it becomes oh I
just did it and so it's not impressive
when it happens no actually one of the
reasons why I think the community has
turned around now
raise has been nerfed on the ability to
like kind of boost yourself bounce out
of out of line of sight like that kind
of thing with the with the the satchels
like grenades in this game end up being
much more creative because you can you
can made cypher wireless and cypher
cameras is that sort of thing you can
use like these creative grenades in
order to get on the site in our sort of
lesson in a way that is less impeding to
your team so lots of them lots of I was
in like also like raises mobility is
more interesting than like mobility
right but there's more like active skill
required and creativity require than
just pressing a button and going
straight up and straight forward you
know yeah yeah can we send this whole
section to riot please yeah I think I
think riot have it under control like I
really when we when we like create these
observations or or you know even
criticize the game at certain points
which I think we we haven't really gone
to Florence criticizing it I mean it's
it's with the understanding that riot
has a plan that they're working towards
and the Balor and flower has not yet
bloomed right now it's gonna in a couple
years if this game if we're still
sitting here going all prim stones
forming because know they're highlights
that's a problem okay knee the like like
I'm okay to let the game developed I
have my thoughts on it but I'm okay to
let it show and I think that like rights
also already shown again with with
certain character they have know that
there are like competing philosophies of
design I'm open and I do like I said I'm
having fun playing it right as the
person who sucks at first and shooters
I'm having fun playing Bower in the game
is more for me and I like that you know
but but we are talking about it's like
future potential in each sport or
whatever at which point like let's let
Riot figure it out for a couple more
months before we make any hard calls to
two years from now Devin's gonna be
sitting in his rocket turrets rocking
chair with his wagon going story that's
what I said that's what it's a problem
the rocking chair going rubber tubber's
even grandma's evidence is free of range
pretty much I'll be on my third desk by
that point yeah as many people watch at
a point it out we have sound but Devin
does not have hair
yeah the Heritage tag yeah we're we
we've signed an egg here at the score
you also also notably a 80 year old AG
who wears a blanket around his shoulders
and sits on a wooden chair whether while
he works all day
I'm [__] cold you know I don't know
you want me to say literally turn off
your air conditioning